all right what's going on guys this is
rob and we are back with the uh lives
and deaths of wolverine and um this is
not a wolverine comic
[Laughter]
this comic actually picks up in the
direct aftermath of the events of bro
really the end of hickman's run right so
like inferno um and it basically picks
up with mora mchaggart on the run which
for the first time that i can never
recall in the history of my life i
actually agree with bleeding cool that
if it had been called the deaths of mora
x it probably wouldn't have sold as well
so they just called it the deaths of
wolverine regardless the important thing
here is that following the events of
inferno if you guys recall that video
that we did that more mctaggart is
basically on the land right she's just
running for her life fleeing from
seemingly mystique and destiny that
while the rule is kill no man at the end
of the day it would most likely be one
of those things where the various
mutants specifically the quiet council
would just kind of turn a blind eye to
like what mystique's doing right what
stinking and destiny would be doing in
terms of killing more mctagger because
remember they stripped her of her mutant
powers and so at the moment morgan
mctaggart is just a regular human person
and so what she ends up doing it's
really the same thing that most anybody
would do under this circumstance they
basically just retreat back home right
it's one of those things where it's kind
of like the safe place right she ends up
going back to scotland where in a lot of
ways it all kind of started for her
right the most significant moments in
the history of maura mctaggart took
place in scotland right it's where she
met banshee it's where she first met or
really where her and charles xavier had
worked together regarding uh the initial
younger mutants who would go on to
become the new mutants team and there's
a lot of history there between the two
of them now of course in her effort to
escape she basically steals the the
vehicle of a guy that's just packed with
sheep right which just kind of seems
like a dick move that basically just
takes off right just just gets out of
there as fast as she possibly can the
problem with this is that she basically
ends up coughing up blood while she's
here and that's when she starts to
realize something's wrong and so at that
point we actually switch over a few days
later to krakowa and the green lagoon
right now you guys know the green lagoon
is basically the bar in kakoa everybody
goes they hang out they party all that
kind of good stuff but then people start
to realize that there's something going
on with black tom's drink right that
something's wrong here they don't know
exactly what it is they suddenly just
know that something's off and so what
this does is it leads to a kind of
investigation where there is this sort
of poking around trying to understand
what's happening now of course as black
tom's doing this is one of those things
where he's like okay there's something
wrong with like the veg right basically
the substance they use to create these
drinks and that while there have been
earthquakes before what seems to be
happening now is something much greater
than what they've experienced and so
once black tom gets to where the veg is
right the source of like the different
drinks and all that kind of stuff
there's just some giant egg that's
growing there and we have no earthly
clue what it means right and so at that
point you basically switch over to the
city of new york now of course this is
more mctaggart getting a kind of exam of
sorts but she's also talking with dr
jane foster who of course you guys know
was previously thought now a lot of this
has to do with the fact and that's kind
of one of the questions people would ask
is why didn't she go to a hospital
anywhere else because jane foster would
be able to keep things under wraps right
jane foster can basically change her
name that kind of a thing because while
jane foster doesn't know everything
that's going on and more mctaggart
doesn't directly clue her in jane foster
knows enough to know who maura mctaggart
is that's seemingly the life and times
of more mctaggart as we've seen them
over the years in marvel comics even
before the events of like jonathan
hickman's house and powers of x and all
that kind of stuff is all seemingly the
same and so while you don't really see
her with a lot of involvement among the
larger superhero community everybody
knows her as the mutant geneticist right
so she just kind of has that level of
respect among the various people who
exist out there in marvel comics but the
information that she gets from jane
foster is that one she's got stage four
lung cancer and two the cancer is
metastasizing so what this does is it
basically gives us a countdown she even
asks for like the petals from cocoa
right those plants that can basically
cure illnesses and we're given a couple
explanations here the first is that the
waiting list for this is enormous which
makes sense there's people out there
with all kinds of illnesses and so on
and so forth and conventional medicines
just don't cure them they're not really
designed to um because of the fact that
these illnesses are so incredibly
advanced but at the same time even if
any of these medicines from kakawa were
available it wouldn't be able to cure
the cancer of more mctaggart now this is
kind of a mainstay of marvel comics and
it's one of those things that marvel
never really bothers to make sense out
of right ever since the death of captain
marvel storyline way back in the day
right back in the 1980s that has been
one of those things where essentially
cancer is like the end-all be-all for
anybody in the superhero community and
it doesn't really matter who they are
now how you reconcile this with someone
who's like an external with a person who
is by all standards of measurement
legitimately immortal meaning they will
never die of any illness or disease or
anything along those lines that the only
way to kill an external mutant is to cut
their head off their shoulders that's it
it's the only way to kill them but if
you never harm them and presumably they
don't really have the power of
indestructibility they will live until
the earth dies right it's just kind of
how those those things exist and that's
assuming they don't find a way off the
earth right they would just continue
living on until the end of all things
basically until the universe collapses
right that's just kind of the gift or
even the curse if you want to look at it
that way of being an external how do you
reconcile that right how do you
reconcile with somebody like thanos or
somebody like wolverine or deadpool or
people like that with a healing factor
and so it's one of those things where
you would have to believe by now if for
no other reason than self-preservation
surely humanity would have found a way
to take the healing factor of somebody
out there whether they take it by hooker
by crook and then use that as a means to
basically create a cure for cancer even
if krakowa hadn't done it because we
have to believe that somebody like
wolverine or deadpool wouldn't be able
to die from cancer i mean it's just one
of those things marvel never really
reconciles it's just kind of like if
you're a hero and you get cancer that's
the end of you done right and that's
just that's just kind of that's how they
treat it and so as a result of this of
course jane foster asked more about
tiger like what's going on like like
what you know why are you not going to
kakoa in order to get these medicines
like what's happening here and of course
maura doesn't really give up the good
she doesn't really give like a full-on
explanation and in fact it's one of
those things where jane foster is like
you came here asking for a favor and i'm
happy to help in any way i can but i
need to know more why are you coming to
me instead of them and the response is i
think i'm already dead and so the
response to jane foster is then won't
they be happy to hear that's not the
case and the response to maura is not
the ones who want me buried right so
she's very very cloak and dagger here
she just doesn't really give much of an
explanation in terms of what's going on
now of course this leads to a nurse
coming in and telling dr foster there's
some kind of an emergency you got to go
check it out and so when dr foster
leaves this nurse is like it's so it's
it's like what is it like steve austin
and vince mcmahon from like the wwf back
in the night like oh i'll take it from
here nurse you know and then just like
it turns out to be mystique who tries to
kill a mormon tiger those of you guys
who don't know what i'm talking about
it's one of the best moments of the
monday night wars but the important
thing here is that once mystique
launches this attack it basically
solidifies all bets are off but it's not
one of those things where more
mctaggart's human therefore she is hands
off it's one of those things where it's
like whatever who cares right and even
if there was a punishment at the end of
the day mystique is willing to to accept
it right whatever punishment she is made
to forgo she'll accept it in the midst
of this whole thing suddenly jane foster
shows up as valkyrie now for those of
you guys who aren't following this and i
don't blame you if you don't jane foster
after she be after she stopped being
thor she was amazing when she was thor
anybody who disagrees with me is wrong
once that was done they just kind of
shuffled her off to the cornfields and
and turned her into a valkyrie and she's
just kind of been there ever since but
that's basically the gist of it right i
mean she had her own solo series for a
little while i think it got cancelled it
was okay but it wasn't nearly as good as
jason aaron's thor run where she was
thor uh but the whole thing behind this
is that she kind of shows up here right
it's just kind of okay i will buy you
time now the irony behind this is that
we can kind of interpret this two-fold
one either it really is jane foster just
rescuing more mctaggart and buying her
the time she needs or two more mctaggard
is definitively going to die because the
valkyries only ever show up to a person
when they're dead or dying and that's it
right that's the only time you ever
really see them like they whisk them
away to basically the afterlife valhalla
and so on and so forth now of course it
really seems to be here that she's
basically just rescuing maura mctaggart
and mormie taggart literally lunges out
of a lunges out of like a window right
just like jumps out of this thing but
when you switch back over to like black
tom cassidy and everything going on in
cocoa where black tom is basically
investigating there's a portal that
opens and then when it does he basically
gets killed by whoever it is that
entered into this portal now again his
death doesn't matter they can always
resurrect him using the five but at the
end of the day the big thing that goes
on here and what's kind of interesting
is the story just kind of hops and skips
around even for the realm of comic books
it's a little questionable like morgan
mctaggart jumping out of a window okay
well how did she survive doesn't matter
she's basically just making her way and
just trying to find some way to get away
from mystique and she doesn't know if
the person looking at her funny is
mystique or anything like that it's one
of the things that makes her so
dangerous is that mystique could
literally be anybody and because she's
been around for so long and because
she's so deadly she could just be some
kindly old woman who walks by you and
then just reaches up and slashes your
throat and no one realizes what happened
you just collapse and you die and
mystique just keeps on going and no one
has any clue what took place right maybe
not even the cameras would catch it if
she knows where the cameras are and so
she's basically just kind of walking
around trying to find a place to hide
getting various you know ways to create
a disguise for herself but while all
that's going on the really mutant task
force for the cia is monitoring
everything and when they realize that
more mctaggart is out there following
the incident in the hospital when
mystique and moore mctaggart have gotten
into a fight they're like okay so
basically mutants are bringing their
various conflicts to the doorstep of the
united states and that was kind of the
big agreement right the big agreement
even if it was somewhat unwritten like
kind of a silent treaty was that you
stay away we stay away right we as the
cia and the x-men task force right the x
desk we will watch you and we will make
sure that you do not become a credible
threat there were a couple attempts to
basically take them out and those never
really succeeded but as long as you
don't come here to our shores right and
as long as you don't bring your problems
to the united states then i guess we can
kind of be on good terms this is
breaking that quiet treaty and basically
now it's like grab more mctaggart right
so now not only does she have to contend
with mystique trying to kill her now
she's got to contend with the cia
tracking her down and so that's what's
kind of crazy is because as she makes
her way and just kind of continues on
she's able to dodge the various security
staff that she sees the obvious members
of the cia who were there because they
have earpieces and apparently they don't
understand what it means to just kind of
be unnoticeable right to just sort of be
quiet as opposed to making a whole bunch
of noise but of course they end up
stumbling upon her and catching her when
they do all hell breaks loose right like
they literally try to shoot her she
grabs guns you know shots start going
off and all that kind of stuff she bails
she steals somebody's motorcycle and
then basically races off and so while
she's making her escape going on to do
her own thing what you do is you switch
back to the cradle where the actual
wolverine is again being strapped to a
table so he can essentially have his
mind sent into the past and save the
life of xavier over the course of what
seems to be the various history of
various historical points in his own
life and xavier's life so that xavier
will survive to the modern era but then
jean grey realizes something's off right
like there's something going on here and
using her telepathic powers she realizes
that what it looks like is wolverine is
the one out there who would kill black
tom cassidy and is causing all these
problems but it looks like a technophage
version of wolverine right like a
machine version of wolverine you know
and he's like i'm no one i was never
here and then just kind of takes off so
here's what we're gonna do i mean
obviously this comic book is everywhere
right and obviously it makes no damn
sense whatsoever uh which is really kind
of disappointing because to be honest
with you guys i mean this story was
written by benjamin percy and benjamin
percy never disappoints so maybe it's
one of these things where the story gets
a lot better as it goes on but right now
this is not a wolf range story i don't
know why it's called the 10 deaths of
wolverine it should be called like the
death of maury mctaggart which again
they probably didn't do that because
nobody cares about maura mctaggart and
if there was a book that was called mora
x nobody would buy it so that's probably
why they called it this so i will leave
it to you guys do you want me to
continue covering this or do you not
care now i'll continue to read it so if
something really really cool happens
later on down the line then maybe we'll
bring it back but if you guys are like
rob this story is ass i don't care no
one's interested then uh then yeah we'll
just kind of cut it loose right i'll
look at the analytics when i'll look at
the the audience retention all that kind
of stuff and get a feel for whether or
not people like it beyond the vocal
minority in the comments section but let
me know what you guys think down there
and uh yeah i will catch you all later
peace